♪ ♪
>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT
MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES AND FOR THAT WE TURN TO
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RAYMOND ARROYO.
THE BIDENS DID A BIG PUSH THIS
WEEK WITH -- THEIR SHOPS DIDN'T
ALL HIT, DID THEY?
>> LIKE THE VACCINE IN SOME
CASES.
THE VACCINE RELUCTANCE OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND HISPANICS
THIS WAY, LAURA.
>> THERE'S A REASON WHY IT'S
BEEN HARDER TO GET
AFRICAN-AMERICANS INITIALLY TO
GET VACCINATED, BECAUSE THEY ARE
USED TO BEING EXPERIMENTED ON.
ALL THE HORROR AS
WELL TO GET LATINX VACCINATED AS
WELL.
WHY?
THEY ARE WORRIED THEY'RE GOING
TO GET VACCINATED AND DEPORTED.
>> THERE'S SO MUCH MORE.
FIRST OF ALL, VICTIMS OF THE
SYPHILIS EXPERIMENT AND HE --
AIRMEN ARE TWO ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHO SHARED OUR
TOWN.
IT'S LIKE SAYING WE OWE A LOT TO
THE NATIVE AMERICAN CHIEFS, LIKE
THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS.
NO, ONE GROUP OF TRIBAL LEADERS
AND THE OTHER THE FOOTBALL TEAM.
AS FOR THE LATINX, OR AS YOU SAY
"LATINX," THIS IS EVEN MORE
CONCERNING.
FIRST OFF, I DON'T KNOW ANY
HISPANICS IN MY FAMILY OR
ANYWHERE ELSE THAT USE LATINX.
THEY JUST -- ONLY 3% OF MOSTLY
YOUNG PEOPLE EVEN ENTERTAIN THAT
TERM.
I DON'T THINK IT IS EVEN THAT
HIGH.
AND THE IDEA THAT HISPANICS ARE
THE BIDEN THANKS HISPANICS
AREN'T GETTING VACCINATED
BECAUSE THEY FEAR DEPORTATION, I
KNOW A LOT OF HISPANICS RIGHT
HERE IN NEW ORLEANS I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE HIM TO.
NONE OF THEM FEAR DEPORTATION,
BY THE WAY.
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, WHO IN
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW WHATEVER
FEAR DEPORTATION INCLUDING
CONVICTED MURDERERS?
OKAY, I DON'T SEE THAT ANYONE IS
GETTING DEPORTED ANYTIME SOON.
WE CAN JUST ALLAY THE CONCERNS
OF ANYONE -- BIDEN WANTS YOU TO
STAY FOREVER AND VOTE DEMOCRAT
AND SO DOES HARRIS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN NEEDED A LOT
OF HELP THIS WEEK.
HIS HANDLERS HAD THEIR HANDS
FULL TRYING TO KEEP THEM ON
SCHEDULE AND KAMALA HARRIS PLAY
THE ROLE OF PROMPT OR TO REMIND
THEM OF THE SURFSIDE BUILDING
COLLAPSE.
WATCH.
>> Reporter: WE TRAVEL TO
FLORIDA?
>> OH, YES, I APOLOGIZE,
THANK YOU.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH,
COINCIDENTALLY, THE MAYOR OF
MIAMI.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU WORRIED
THAT THE -- FOURTH OF JULY
CELEBRATION?
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> Laura: COME ON, THIS WAY,
COME, COME.
THE HAND PUSHING HIM OFF STAGE
OR OFF --
>> SOMETIMES YOU NEED A LITTLE
MORE HELP.
HARRISON FORD, WHO WAS A YEAR
OLDER THAN JOE BIDEN JUST
INJURED HIMSELF ON THE SIDE OF
THE NEW INDIANA JONES MOVIE IN
LONDON.
MAYBE IF HE HAD HAD SOME
HANDLERS, "INDIANA JONES AND THE
FRACTURED SHOULDER BLADE" WOULD
STILL BE FILMING.
YOU NEED FRIENDS TO SAVE YOU
FROM YOURSELF SOMETIMES.
>> Laura: I'M VERY CONFUSED, I
THOUGHT "INDIANA JONES" WAS
ALREADY CANCELED BECAUSE HE WAS
TOO MANLY OR TOO CHIVALROUS OR
KISSED THE WRONG PERSON?
I THOUGHT THAT WAS ALL OUT THE
WINDOW.
>> KISSED THE YOUNG GIRL.
>> Laura: OH, I GOT.
>> HE'S IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
CANCELED.
JILL BIDEN HIT THIS OUT THIS
WEEK TO PUSH VACCINES IN
TENNESSEE, MISSISSIPPI AND
FLORIDA.
THIS IS PART OF HER "WE CAN DO
THIS" TOUR.
JILL BIDEN TRIED TO WOO THEM
WITH AN INSULT.
>> THIS STATE STILL HAS A LITTLE
BIT OF A WAY TO GO.
ONLY THREE IN TEN TENNESSEANS
ARE VACCINATED --
[BLUING]
>> YOU ARE BOO-ING YOURSELF.
>> ONLY THREE PEOPLE SHOWED UP,
AND THAT WAS WITH FREE BEER.
THEY'VE GOT TO DO BETTER THAN
THE SPIRITS >> Laura: I'M
SURPRISED, WITH THE DOCTOR
TITLE, WHICH IS SO ENDEARING,
DOCTOR, RIGHT HERE, PLEASE.
I'M ON MY SECOND SHOT NOW.
NO, NO, A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
DOCTOR.
I'VE GOT A J.D., CAN I BE
DR. LAURA?
>> WE WILL START CALLING YOU
DR. LAURA.
>> Laura: IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
STETHOSCOPE HANGING AROUND YOUR
NECK, OKAY, I'M OLD SCHOOL THAT
WAY.
I DON'T KNOW.
TO ME, I DON'T KNOW, IT'S
CONFUSING.
>> THEY MAY HAVE TO RENAME THIS
TO HER "WE CAN'T DO THIS."
THE FIRST LADY'S COMMENTS IN
MISSISSIPPI MAKES PLAIN WHY
THERE'S SO MUCH VEXING
HESITANCY.
LISTEN CLOSELY.
>> SCIENTISTS HAVE BEEN STUDYING
SIMILAR VIRUSES AND WORKING ON
THIS TYPE OF VACCINE FOR DECADES
SO WHEN THIS PANDEMIC STARTED
THEY ALREADY HAD A PANDEMIC
READY TO GO.
>> THEY GOT THAT PANDEMIC READY
TO GO, DR. LAURA.
JILL BIDEN WILL BE DRIVING THE
PACE CAR AT NASCAR NEX